believing is seeing where I come from is  not so different from here just have a  look around in many places of the world  people with disabilities are seen as  outsiders but my greatest weakness has  also been my greatest strength as a  blind boy in Iran I didn't really have  an eye on what the other kids were doing  but my ears were tuned in to music and  radio as a 20 year old immigrant in  Germany I was disappointed by the fact  that I didn't see one faults wagon when  I showed up but it was easy for me to  pick up on language and that made my  journey easier I always wanted to serve  as a cultural emissary between my two  homelands to highlight the nuances of  the two societies and in order to do  this I chose journalism where most  people see the world I experience it as  a symphony one that I have to listen to  until the end to complete the picture  and it is my job to translate what I  experience to audiences around the world  my name is Eskander Abadi and I work at  GW